hey guys it is the 24th of every today
you my name is Jess McDonald and you are
watching games watch news first up the
Xbox one is getting a price cut in the
UK the original price has been cut by 30
pounds so now gamers can pay just 400
pounds for the console which is still a
lot by comparison the Xbox one currently
costs an equivalent of 300 pounds in the
USA of America the cut will come into
effect on the 28th of this month though
Microsoft says they haven't got plans to
make the deal any sweeter for any other
territories at the moment part of the
price cut involves Microsoft's a brand
new limited edition titanfall bundle
where you can grab a download code for
the shooter as well as the console for
400 pounds are you gonna pick this one
up or do you reckon the price needs to
come down further let me know as for our
resolution story of the day Microsoft
hosted the Xbox one has no trouble
running at 1080p Xbox executive Harvey
Eagle also recipient of the coolest name
ever award has said that it's up to
individual developers to balance
resources in a way that delivers the
performance they want out of the black
box Eagle also said power isn't
reflected by pixels and polygon counts
but rather hardware software and the
cloud where do you agree with that one
or not Eagle went on to admit that the
console has had its shortcomings in the
first few months on the market but that
it's working on these and actively
improving upon them and the last thing
you'll probably care about today is that
Assassin's Creed will not be bringing
one of its white-footed protagonist to
feudal Japan Assassin's Creed v weren't
to be making its way to feudal Japan
according to Ubisoft Toronto boss chief
Raymond in a new ad week profile though
she did say it was an interesting idea
she won't tell us when it's going to be
set but she did say it's in her favorite
historical era so any rating of her
Facebook Likes all courses she took in
university would be greatly appreciated
by AP fans everywhere we haven't
received
word of the 2014 released but given that
the series is annual it's a pretty solid
chance we'll be seeing another entry
this year if not - according to earlier
rumors right now my money and personal
preference is on that last one but let
me know where you'd like to see the next
game set either in the comments down
below or you can do so on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald's if you do
find yourself with this fare minute be
sure to check out our brand new show the
lobby where we'll be giving you prizes
playing games chatting the deaths and
all sorts of other good stuff will be
airing on Tuesday at 2 p.m. PST that's
it for me for today but I'll be back
tomorrow with yet more news so come join
me again then and I'll see you soon